hello everyone
i'm alana and i have decided
to make
some changes i have no idea if this is
the right call
i guess we'll see and if it is not the
right call
then
we'll just take everything back
hopefully it won't be a disaster
um
so i've had this channel for like 10
years now and this whole time it's just
been it's it's been a personal channel
where i just inevitably end up talking
about video games most of the time i
just kind of upload whatever i want and
that has led to a confused audience
um there are definitely people who have
subscribed to my channel for really
specific things or who found me from
really specific things and now the array
of stuff that i have i just don't feel
like all belongs it doesn't make sense i
think it's very weird to have
uh video game writing 101 which is a
pretty serious podcast where i talk to
two generally esteemed video game
writers every month on the same channel
that idiots abroad
idiots and abroad is on which is a
comedy podcast that is um
very explicit so explicit that it
frequently gets demonetized on youtube
and red lips orange car which is my
podcast with pioneer nova and charlotte
uh avery
which
is all about internet dating and is also
very explicit um while also doing
serious dev interviews it's just it's
weird
and
for i've been thinking this for probably
two years
that i need to shift uh some stuff
so that
i'm i'm organized a little bit better
and my thoughts are a little bit better
organized but also so that i'm
representing the content that i make in
a better way and not like
discrediting the serious content that i
make and the serious people that i have
on here by also featuring them next to a
youtube video that is personal that is
titled something like i got my eyebrows
tattooed um
and it certainly applies to my audience
where
my personal content gets a lot of views
because a lot of people know me
personally um
but every time that i upload a personal
video i lose a lot of subscribers which
is from all of the people who have
subscribed for the gaming content
because that's a majority of what i make
going i didn't subscribe for this i
subscribe for gaming that's what you
make most of the time what the [ __ ] is
this weird [ __ ] that you just uploaded
so
i've decided to split the two
the place you are right now youtube.com
charlanazad is going to be my gaming
entertainment channel uh i will continue
to upload
gaming podcast which is video game
writing 101 uh as soon as i can launch
voice acting 101 i will launch that here
too those are both patreon supported
play watch listen play watch listen
we'll stay here developer interviews um
the hour-long let's plays that i do
the gaming q and a's that i do every
month um any unboxings uh trailer
reactions and i've started doing more
news as well um which is more like me
discussing the news than reporting the
news obviously but more of that too
because i just like talking about video
games and
obviously uh play watch listen my gaming
podcast is something that i intend to
talk about gaming news but often doesn't
and i still want to fill that void um
the sort of ongoing thing that i've been
doing with skill up and yong yeah and
jake valdino um as well so
youtube.com which is where you are right
now is going to host my gaming and
entertainment content uh i've started a
new channel that i'm trying to pick a
name for
it's either going to be lana pierce irl
or alana and friends
we'll have the other stuff so idiots
that abroad will be on the second
channel i think probably alana and
friends makes the most sense
alana irl's shorter i don't know maybe
you guys can help me um red lips orange
car will go over there and then i'm also
going to get to make more stuff there
that i've been wanting to make for a
long time that just hasn't fit here like
i had been meaning to do this video for
a really long time where i put makeup on
and i have like maybe john jacob and
rahul narrate so like i'll do it really
slowly and i'll wear more than i would
normally wear and i'll have them explain
what i'm doing or like videos where they
do my makeup or
some more silly vlogs um
so the personal q a's are going to start
going on that channel instead of on this
channel
um and i intend to mostly have it be
just silly fun extra stuff that's like
more
i don't know
just ridiculous like maybe we make some
wild vlogs um we could do like a vlog
with jacob building gundam stuff that
i just
like have been meaning to make and have
thought about making that i didn't
really have a place for of course like
some of the vloggy stuff is going on
patreon for idiots and abroad but
uh i just want to make more weird stuff
there that is like very easy content to
make doesn't require much editing
doesn't really require much extra effort
but it's just like more fun
and very different in tone to the stuff
that i make here so
that's the plan
the most important thing
is idiots and abroad and red lips orange
car moving people are probably gonna ask
me about that for like six months um and
i expect this to probably hurt views for
those shows pretty significantly at
least to begin with um but i'm not
really worried about it they're
supported by patreon anyway so losing
views uh doesn't really matter um
yeah i just think it's gonna make more
sense so there will be a
personal channel
it feels weird to call it a personal
channel because it's not like i'm gonna
start delving into a bunch of personal
[ __ ] that i'm not comfortable talking
about anyway but like more vloggy silly
weird stuff that doesn't have anything
to do with gaming um
outside of maybe like we do a warhammer
painting or gundam building or whatever
else um
just like more fun stuff with friends
and then
this channel
will stay gaming so let's plays will
still be here some stream highlight
stuff will still be here
um there will still be the gaming q and
a's all that stuff so
yeah i don't know it's just something i
kind of want to do for a while
especially because i'm very happy with
the gaming content that i'm making i
think that the podcasts are very very
good um play watch listen actually just
won an award we won an award for uh at
the the 2022 communicator awards we want
a communication award for excellence in
communication which is super cool um so
i think that stuff is really good
obviously it's very like low effort
because it's not my full-time job but i
think it's like good quality and it just
feels so weird to have like this
interview with the founder of devolver
digital and like i recently had
the founder of arcane the guy who
created dishonest
and then the next episode is like we
rate your dating profiles i just think
it's just
it's just weird um
so yes going to split the two up i think
it'll make more sense to my audience i
think it'll make more sense to the
professionals that i have
on the channel for me to keep it a
little bit more gaming it's not gonna
say it's gonna be more professional
still have like silly let's plays um and
still do fun stuff obviously and still
make fun content but just like taking
anything that's not like tv movies uh or
games off and making more weird content
that i otherwise haven't
had a spot for so like i said i think
it's a good idea i think it makes sense
i think it will appease the audiences
who've been
like i do always lose subscribers when i
upload personal content for the personal
content gets so many views um so clearly
people are interested in that but then
this most people sub for gaming content
so when i upload it the subs are like
what it's people's like recommended
feeds that the personal content is
coming up in so i think it makes sense
to separate those two
for those audiences um and yeah i think
it'll
like i'll be able to make more fun stuff
with my friends is kind of the idea so i
don't know how much i'll be able to
upload on the second channel which i'm
still trying to figure out the name for
uh it won't be as frequent as the gaming
channel but um
i my first plan is to vlog
a trip to florida i'm going to see
youtuber boxing um my friend aaron is is
boxing harley
so that's game grumps versus epic meal
time
and i'm very excited to see it so i
thought i might vlog that and that's the
kind of thing that like i wouldn't
have ever like i've always been like oh
that could be an interesting thing to
shoot but i would never put on this
channel because it wouldn't make any
sense um doesn't fit so
i'm gonna do that and put it on the
personal channel
and
yeah i thought like i said like i think
doing like making jacob do my makeup
and
i used to do these drunk advice segments
i thought that maybe i would do another
one of those
the personal q and a's will be once a
month over there gaming will be once a
month here
um
and yeah vlogs of like different stuff
like travel vlogs
stuff that i've done a little bit of on
here but just
don't do because i don't feel like i
should um so yeah don't know how often
i'll upload but that is going to be
moving over
i suspect yeah views on both channels
will probably like decrease and then
i don't know hopefully it makes sense to
people it makes more sense in my head
and i feel like kind of in a weird way
gives me more freedom um and also i just
think that yeah the gaming content i'm
making here is good the podcasts are
good
there aren't a lot of people making
stuff like them on youtube there are a
lot of people who have access to devs
like i do on youtube so
it just feels like it makes sense to
have them here and the other stuff
all the stupid stuff elsewhere
it's like i'm so insecure about my
twitter because
people like herman holst and phil
spencer follow me and i just tweet so
many
stupid memes you know
that this is me
removing the dumb meme content from my
youtube feed for any dev who i asked to
like come talk to me about something so
that they don't have to deal with the
random extra garbage that i enjoy
posting but that i don't think fits here
so
that's the plan gaming content is not
going to be changing if anything
there'll be more of it i'm going to
start doing a little bit more news topic
um discussion stuff uh because the way
that i can do it the way i figured out
the last two videos that i've done are
actually fast enough for me to be able
to make efficiently that was the thing
that always got me was working full-time
it's really hard to stay up to date but
i'm making them in a really fast way so
it does work
and um
yeah more creative
funny hopefully stuff on the other
channel that i think will largely always
feature friends i'll have probably a few
personal videos that are just me
um there are some topics that i wanted
to delve into that i never wanted to
talk about here like
uh
i came out as pansexual a few years ago
that's something i've literally never
spoken about on youtube because it
doesn't make sense here i'll probably do
that over there or being neurodivergent
or
whatever else all the stuff that i don't
think fits on this channel so
stuff that i will talk about there by
myself mostly going to be with friends
uh mostly funny vlog content with a
bunch of cool people i know
um i've had ideas for videos that i
wanted to make with people like
like ethan or eddie burback
um
other friends who live in la that just
didn't make sense on that channel so
that's the plan
again don't think output is going to be
huge on there but we'll have both of the
podcasts it is an abroad android lips
orange car
as a reminder i will leave a link in the
description and a pin comment and i will
probably be reminding people for several
videos uh ongoing from this point just
so they don't miss that information so
that they are confused about where the
podcast went
um
and that's it really
just wanted to give an update i think i
covered it all thank you for watching i
hope you enjoy the new channel if not i
hope that you enjoyed that this one will
just be video games which certainly a
lot of people have complained about so
that's pretty much it i'll see you guys
there bye